listen I've been a fan of yours for a
long time but there's going to be people
out there who've never seen anything
you've done besides Oppenheimer which is
obviously incredible uh what would be
the thing you want people to watch first
if they've never seen your work oh
that's a good question uh I hate looking
at my own films
um I would probably there's a film I
have a great affection for that I made
in Ireland called to win the chase The
Barley which is a film I'm very proud of
so it's a little uh insight into Irish
history but it's a beautifully made film
by Ken Loch yeah yeah he's okay he's
pretty good right uh what is it actually
like for you you've worked with Nolan
before but what was it actually like
when he reached out to you and said I'm
thinking about doing Oppenheimer I think
I want you or I want you to do the role
as an actor
what is that like getting that call oh
listen I think any actor in the world
would first of all want to work with
Chris but second of all to do a lead for
him you know it's a
can't think of any better words and it's
a dream it sounds like such a cliche but
it's the truth but I had no I had no
idea he was going to call me he just
called me out of the blue that's his
ammo he just like you never hear from
him and then calls him so he called me
and I didn't I don't I genuinely didn't
know what it would be and then he
started making this movie about
Oppenheimer and I would like to play
so it's just this big shock and a very
Pleasant one but then you kind of go
okay I have a lot of work to do
completely so what is it like you get
off the phone with him and are you
immediately in your head like I need to
just start studying uh yes yes exactly
that and I knew then he told me the date
we were starting to shoot so I knew I
had six months
to really go in but I would have taken
more but six months was good and we just
went straight at it from that day we
were just into it one of the things
about this film is obviously it was
filmed with IMAX cameras and it's
incredible but as an actor what is it
like when because it's a huge camera
yeah what is it like when it's right
there near you and you know every shot
is incredibly expensive and it's also
incredibly loud you kind of get used to
it you know you do and I'm a bit of a
Nolan veteran so I'm kind of used to the
huge cameras and the and then the racket
they make
um but we we have amazing DP um you know
uh an amazing camera team so
it doesn't become a big deal after all
and if you started thinking oh this is
going to be my face you know 80 foot on
them you just can't think about it like
that and Chris never talked about it
like that he just cares about the
performances what's happening in the
moment and the truths the truth of the
scene you know I'm sure when you looked
at the schedule and you saw everything
you're going to be doing you maybe had a
day or two circled in terms of oh that
might be a tough day you know what I
mean so what was that day or two that
you had circled or you were in your head
a little bit uh in terms of the
performance or what was required of you
that day to be honest with you they were
all like that
but the day the the section of the movie
that I I loved uh working on the most
was the section in the room 2022 and we
were all in the hearing and we we shot
in this tiny shitty little room uh and
there weren't any like like movable
walls or anything that it was just all
of us in there and with this this huge
camera but that felt almost like um
doing a play we did that for two weeks
so all these incredible actors in you
know Jason Clark and then everybody
would come in and do their do their
piece and I found it very emotional and
heavy but in a brilliant way like um was
a real challenge so that was my favorite
chunk of the movie in terms of shooting
it uh what do you think would surprise
Christopher Nolan fans to learn about
making a Christopher Nolan movie
um
he's not that sympathetic to toilet
breaks
not what I expected you to say and it's
also very honest I'll I'll leave that
there the other thing is I'm fascinated
by the way directors crafter performance
so what was it like on set when because
clearly Chris is looking for things in
each take and he knows exactly what he
wants yeah what does he like to work
with when he when he's not getting
exactly what he wants out of you is he
does he direct like is it quiet like I'm
thinking you know what I mean could you
talk a little bit about how he directed
you
brilliant with actress understands
actors loves actors
um really believes in actors and and
what they can bring to to the to the
story Into the to the character
um so an awful lot of the time we'll
just find it we'll be shooting but we'll
be finding the scene and he let us
experiment and explore stuff and then he
may come in and he'll just kind of just
whisper very quietly in your ear and
generate the notes a very precise and
succinct and brief where they can like
totally
spin the performance and that's his
genius and also comes to the fact that
he's written it so you know he's direct
access to it
um
but he's phenomenal like really
phenomenal so I I saw this last night in
IMAX 70 millimeter and it is amazing
like the seeing it in that first of all
the movie is incredible but also that
presentation
um have you seen it in IMAX 70. I've
seen it in like 70. I'm going to I'm
looking forward I've seen the other
other Chris's other movies in in that
format and I can't cannot wait to see it
is it going to tweak you a little bit in
terms of when you see your face on that
huge screen can you can you sit through
some actors I speak to they really can't
watch themselves I don't enjoy it I
don't know many actors that do love
looking at themselves
um
but I love watching it with an audience
because that's what Cinema is isn't it
it's it's that you know a lot of
strangers in a dark room collectively
invested in this thing so watching it on
your own in the screen room is not the
same I want to watch it with an audience
you know 100 I've seen movies just like
you in a small like with nobody and it
doesn't have the same impact the energy
of everyone yeah you know um so I'm
curious what is it like or what was it
like for you reading the script for the
first time because he wrote the
Oppenheimer stuff in a different way
than anyone like could you talk a little
bit about that yeah so he wrote the
script in the first person which I never
encountered and never experienced and it
like it blew my mind it also I realized
that that was a huge responsibility
because everything is kind of
subjectively through oppenheimer's eyes
except for the black and white bits
which are
um objectively from strauss's point of
view
um but yeah it was it was one of the
best screenplays I've ever read without
a shadow out but so for example you
would say it wouldn't say like
Oppenheimer walks into the room and
speaks to trolls and say I walk into the
room and I walk over and so he said
That's How It Was Written you know I
can't I I can't imagine as because
you've read so many screenplays it's
never like that never never well not my
experience ever yeah I'm sure every
script would be like this now they'll
all be coughing Chris uh that wouldn't
come as a surprise so uh if you were to
do a Nolan double feature with
Oppenheimer what is the other movie you
would watch with it that's a good
question
and do you think it should complement it
or can it be kind of random it could be
anything actually it's just your uh I
mean if you wanted a science double
build you'd probably go for Interstellar
right
um which I absolutely adore that movie
um
I don't know you could if you wanted a
completely different one you could you
could if you wanted a completely palette
cleanser you could watch Like The
Prestige or something which is also I
think one of Chris's
undervalued but brilliant films so um I
don't know what do you think honestly I
don't know I I uh Inception would be an
interesting one yeah like but I mean all
of his movies you know as long as I
could see it in an IMAX theater would be
great yeah like a double you know what I
mean yeah yeah so uh there's been talk
there's a different thing there's been
talk of a 28 months later sequel but
you're starting to reach the point where
is it better to do 28 years later I I I
I was um talking to Danny Boyle recently
I said Danny I think it's we Shot the
movie and
tooth at the end of 2000. so I think
we're definitely approaching the 28
years later uh but like I've always said
I'm up for it I'd love to do it if Alex
if Alex thinks there's a script in it
and Danny wants to do it I'd love to do
it I think the 28 years is way better
just because you've it would be
reflection of your you have aged how
ancient I am
the thing you know what I mean my last
thing for you uh the movie's about three
hours but I'm assuming there were
deleted scenes do you remember any
deleted scenes or were there a lot of
deleted scenes there's no deleted scenes
in Chris Nola movies really that's why
there's no like DVD extras in on his
movies because he just the script is the
movie
that's all because he knows exactly
what's going to end up he's not you know
fiddling around with it trying to change
the story he that is the movie that's
amazing
um on that note I gotta go I'm just
gonna say man you are fantastic in this
I wish you nothing but the best time
thanks so much